so I think we can all agree that Mad Max
fury road is one of the best movies ever
made now having said that if you're
anything like me you probably found
yourself asking the question is there
anything regarding the origin stories of
the various characters or an origin
story of Max is there an origin story of
immortus Joe of knucks of Charlize
Theron character are there any origin
stories for this not everybody has an
origin story yet but there is an origin
story for knucks and in this video we're
going to find out what it is so the
origin story of knucks comes to us in
the Mad Max fury road comic adaptation
by vertigo and vertigo is basically the
indie branch of DC Comics much like
image is the indie branch of Marvel
Comics then what we're told here is that
knucks actually grew up during the
post-nuclear ravaged world in Australia
but not much is known or not much has
told us about his parents it's presumed
that his parents had grown up in regular
society before this nuclear war had
taken place at Ritter that pretty much
just led to the degradation of society
as a whole but instead of actually
giving us that we're basically just kind
of given this this post-apocalyptic
environment where some people sell their
children others sell themselves and some
sell whatever they have for food
clothing weapons and especially water
since water is such a rare commodity in
this society what we're also told here
is that among this dystopian society are
the parents of knucks who actually don't
succumb to the violent nature of those
around them instead they basically rely
on each other and seem to maintain
what's left of organized society in
themselves and a sense that rather than
actually selling knucks as a child
rather than selling themselves they
instead barter with people they do what
they can to try to to maintain this
standard of organized society before
everything collapsed but in addition to
all this what we learn is that knucks
and his family actually live within the
confines of immortan joe's society but
when a massive storm actually comes
through Nexxus family is killed now
while the initial presumption is that
his family dies in the storm
vertigo actually they kind of leave it
ambiguous to be honest then we don't
really know if they died in the storm or
if they were simply murdered but
regardless what happens is that when
immortan joe lowers the platform to
allow a select few to join his inner
circle and a citadel that knucks as a
two-year-old tries to climb onto the
platform now this is really interesting
here because what we get is basically
the circumstance where the war boys the
henchmen of immortan joe sort of go
ducks in the sense that they want to see
whether or not he can do it on his own
and this really gives an indication of
just how far gone this group is from
organized society that they're not going
to help a toddler climb up onto a
platform instead if Knox Falls well then
that just sucks and it just means that
he wasn't worthy and that's it I mean
they relish him it's they laugh about it
they enjoy seeing a two-year-old
struggle and presumably risk his life
possibly falling to his death but what
ultimately ends up happening here is
that nook is actually able to climb on
to the platform or at least he's able to
get a strong enough grip that one of the
war boys who grabs him and inducks him
into their ranks and this is how Knox
became part of the war boys clan
basically he got the name Knox because
he was a hard nut to crack and so what
we find is that with the movie itself we
basically continue with his character
where he's a mechanic and he's basically
continuing to try to work his way up and
eventually be somebody that can exist at
the side of a Morton Joe and eventually
find himself on the immortal road to
Valhalla well that being said we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end not a whole Lots given to us here
this is a pretty short video but again
this is really all we have in terms of
the origin story of Knox and so if you
guys enjoyed this video if this video
was well-received then if people seem to
like it enough then maybe we'll continue
on with the rest of the other Mad Max
videos but with that being said I will
catch you guys in peace
the cream then
you